that are very short.
The sentences are short.
The words are brief.
However, the meaning is all-encompassing
and extensive. And most usually with
these types of narrations, you can apply
it to every single narration. Excuse me,
you can apply it to every single
situation.
They are brief words to live by.
They're what we refer to as idioms or
songs
or what we refer to as
sayings.
All of us as human beings, when we go to
make a decision decision,
whether it be
a an immediate decision, whether it be a
decision that is brief consciously or
subconsciously,
we always refer to rules of thumb to
help us make these decisions.
For instance,
one of the sayings is
one of the sayings that many of us know
is better safe than
better safe than what?
Than sorry. Better safe than sorry,
right? This helps a person choose
whether safety is
the most important
choice or
pleasure or discomfort or what have
you.
We have other sayings
such as
we have things better safe than
sorry or don't count your chickens
before they
hatch, right? Which means deal with the
situation as it presents itself. Don't
put Don't put your eggs all in one
basket, right? We all know these
sayings. And these sayings have a
profound impact on the way we make
decisions. Whether we believe that or
not, each one of these sayings, the
reason we've memorized them and we say
them and oftentimes quote them to each
other at critical moments of decision,
at decisive moments,
the reason is is that these sayings
represent an all-encompassing
rule.
A rule that if you rely on it, you will
most likely make the correct decision.
That's the point of this.
What's sad to see is that many Muslims
have not memorized or learned these
sayings of the prophet Sallallahu alayhi
wasallam or of the Quran.
We have a lot of them,
but we have the best idioms, the
greatest of Psalms and the best
parables.
And so when a person reads a verse,
many verses of the Quran, you'll notice
that they're not really, really long.
They're short.
Just brief sentences. When you open a
book of Hadith,
you'll notice that most of the prophet's
words and narrations are brief. Why?
Because he wants them to be memorized.
Because if a person's words are too
many,
it'd be difficult to memorize them. It'd
be difficult to understand them. And so
one of his miracles that he was given
was a miracle that that he says what
jawami' al-kalim. And I have been given
the exten- extensive, expansive,
most comprehensive
word knowledge in the shortest of terms.
This is called jawami' al-kalim.
Good example of this from the Quran such
as
for instance.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says, "And no
soul shall bear the burden of any other
soul."
This is an idiom. This is something that
Allah repeats through the Quran in order
to in order that it be committed to
memory.
and so forth. Here we have one of these
narrations.
And this is a narration that al-Nawawi
placed in his book of 40 Hadith. If you
want to ask, "What is a book that
compiles
these idioms?" a book of narrations
that are handpicked
to serve exactly this purpose. Just like
we have, "Don't put all your eggs in one
basket. Better safe than sorry. Don't
count your chickens before they hatch.
Just between you and you and me and the
fence post." Stuff that that we
say. What do we have in that vein that
is
provided by the scholars of Islam? Well,
the the book that all of us know that
first comes to mind and that was
made and written for that purpose
exactly is which book?
Who knows?
Huh?
Al-Arba'in al-Nawawiyyah. The 40
narrations of al-Hafidh al-Nawawi. They
were later completed as 50 narrations by
al-Hafidh ibn Rajab. And that is the
entire purpose of that book. That those
42 narrations, and if you add the eight
narrations of
Rajab, those 50 narrations, every single
ruling in Islam can be rooted back to
one of those narrations. This is why it
is the first book traditionally
memorized by the students of Hadith. And
this narration is one of those
narrations in the 40 40 narrations.
It's on the authority of
[Arabic recitation]
al-Ansari.
Not to be confused with Ibn Mas'ud.
Ibn Mas'ud is a different He is a
Muhajir.
Abu Mas'ud
al-Ansari, he's also referred to as Abu
Mas'ud al-Badri.
He narrates to us that the prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wasallam said,
[Silence]
These This narration tells us that this
statement, this idiom,
is just It's five words.
This sentence is a wisdom that every
prophet has has brought to his people.
And we have in the Quran many of that.
Surah
al-A'la for instance,
the meanings of Surah al-A'la are
found in the revelations of every single
prophet. Every prophet and messenger,
especially Ibrahim and Musa alayhim
as-salam.
The end of Surah an-Najm
is this as well.
Abu Abu Mas'ud al-Badri narrates that
the prophet sallallahu alayhi wa SALLAM
SAID,
"OF THE sayings of the idioms that
the earlier prophets
brought and the people had received is
the is the statement idha lam tastahi
fasna' ma shi't.
If you have no shame, then do as you
choose. Do as you please.
This narration has been collected by
Imam al-Bukhari. If you have no shame,
do as you please.
This narration, ironically, can be
understood in the positive and the
negative.
It could be understood that
if in your heart of hearts you do not
feel shame in doing this, and had it
been public, you would still do it.
If that is how you feel about it in your
heart of hearts,
then it is probably halal.
That is only for the Muslim, of course.
If a person does a sin long enough, it
will become joyous. It will become
something that is
very common. It will become something
that is
something to boast about. That's not
what's intended here. What's intended is
as a Muslim with a pure heart who
worships Allah and seeks Allah's
approval,
if you go to do something and you feel
that this thing
had it been public, had the prophet
himself been watching me as I do this, I
would still feel comfortable doing it,
then
it is most likely okay. And we have a
other narrations that support this. The
prophet
Alayhi Wasallam was once asked about a
general definition of evil.
What is sinfulness? What is evil?
He said,
He said evil, sinfulness
is what
irritates you in your heart
and you would hate that people see you
do this or say this
or believe this.
That is sinfulness. This is for the
Muslim.
Right? So that is one meaning of the
narration. Ironically, the exact
opposite can be understood from the
narration as well.
Meaning the last
element of faith to depart from a
person's heart is shame.
And if you have no shame, you'll do
anything.
Shame is the last barrier between
humanity
and debauchery.
Humanity and complete misguidance.
The most foul of things, they occur
because shame doesn't exist.
When a person had does had does not have
shame anymore,
this person
will
delve and and and indulge in every kind
of debauchery and sinfulness because
they have no shame.
An interesting story regarding this
narration
is that this narration is the only
that
one of the great students of Imam Malik
rahimahullah
who is referred to as Bundar
he is one of the greatest students of
Imam Malik. He
heard this narration from Shu'bah.
Shu'bah is considered to be Imam
al-Mu'minin
Amir al-Mu'minin fil-Hadith.
Shu'bah is Imam al-Bukhari of his
time.
He's one of the greatest memorizers of
Hadith in the entire ummah.
Now
this
student who wasn't a student at the time
he was drinking with his friends.
And as they were on the street in
Baghdad in Baghdad in Iraq
they saw a man riding a donkey
with thousands of people around him
escorting him to the gates of the city.
He was leaving. He was going on some
some kind of travel.
And they observed this and they thought,
"Who is this superstar? I mean, he's
he's not a king, he's not an emperor,
he's riding a donkey.
Right?
Who is this person?"
And so
he elbows his way through the crowd and
stands right in front of the donkey and
stops the entire procession, the entire
parade.
The amount of gall and arrogance it
takes to be that, to to elbow your
way into the into the center of the
crowd and and draw all attention to
yourself and
a clown.
And so he stands in front of this donkey
and who is upon this donkey? Shu'bah.
And he says to him, "Who are you? What
is all this?"
They said to him, "This is Shu'bah."
He's one of the great narrators of
Hadith. He said, "Who is Shu'bah?" They
said, "Muhaddith."
A person who narrates.
He said,
He then haddithna.
He said, "Okay, so tell me a Hadith
then. If you're a muhaddith,
you're a narrator, narrate to me. Let's
hear it."
And so Shu'bah says to him,
Itha lam tastahi fasna ma shi't.
If you have no shame, you'll do
anything. this.
Look at you.
And so
he was struck by this statement.
It cut him deep.
He never heard words profound this.
In a few words, he completely
gave a different perspective
on this. He was trying to impress his
friends.
And after this, the words affected him
so deeply
that he quit his vices and traveled He
asked, "Who is the greatest scholar of
our time?" He was told, "Malik ibn
Anas." "Where is Malik ibn Anas?" "He's
in Medina." He left for Medina and he
spent the next 20 years in Medina and
became the most prominent student of
Al-Hafidh Malik ibn Anas Rahimahullah.
And so, as he learned and studied, he
started to realize who Shu'bah really
is.
So,
he left after 20 years with Imam Malik
back to Baghdad to find Shu'bah.
Because as a muhaddith, now he
understands
that Malik is a student of Shu'bah and
he had the source right there.
But he was too ignorant to know that.
He went back and found that Shu'bah had
passed away.
Rahimahullah Ta'ala. And so, this is the
only narration
that he has from Shu'bah.
Idha lam tastahi fasna' ma shi'ta.
[Arabic recitation]
wa karamihi wa judih an yu'allimana ma
an taghfiralana wa tarhamana wa tatuba
[Arabic recitation]
fitnatan faqbidna ilaik ghaira maftunin.
ashabihi ajma'in. Walhamdulillah Rabbil
Alamin.
Wa iyyak. Let me tell you something.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]